a lot of people have been thanked
tonight Doozers directors Mexico gotta
thanks and deservedly so many of you
would not be here without the people
you're thanking but there's another
group that I think deserves our thanks
even more because without them none of
us would be here so I want to thank I
would take a moment to thank the people
who actually go to see the movies you
make tonight we thank the movie-going
holy unzip me I don't want us to just
clap applause is nice but I want to
really thank them so the people you see
on screen right now they are across the
way at the TCL Chinese Theatre they
don't know we can see them there we're
watching them on one of those cameras
that have vision in the night what do
they call night vision cameras so they
don't know the cameras there we lured
them into the theatre to see a sneak
preview of the movie or wrinkle in time
and I thought it would be nice if we got
a group together to go over there and
thank them in person to Surprise them so
who wants to come with me by the way
we're looking for stars Ansel would you
like to come with me that would be very
kind of you yes I mean who else mark
would you oh they would get a big kick
out of seeing Luke Skywalker that would
be wonderful
yeah definitely Guillermo you want to
come with us you know you're nominated
in every category so this could
potentially be problematic wonderful oh
good here Guillermo yes I get a medium
Oh
Emily Blunt
they can see what Mary Poppins looks
like in the play wonderful
Oh gal the note oh my god Lupita thank
you okay
some people have trains I think we have
a pretty solid group hero army hammer is
gonna join us as well wonderful
so Paulo Guillermo let's head over and
okay so we are outside theater number
six at the TCL Chinese Theatre got all
these movie stars gathered we've got
snacks what do we have here what do you
have candy candy we got red vines we
have a six-foot sub and we have a hotdog
cannon and so has a hotdog cannon and
army has a hotdog cannon we're gonna
fire hot dogs into the air mo good job
so Gong you come in and won't distract
them and then we'll bring everybody in
as a surprise okay here we go
so here we go who are you doing
[Applause]
I just want to say right off that there
is a strong aroma of marijuana in this
theater preciate what we have first of
all I have an announcement to make you
are live on the Oscars right now
[Applause]
so we were talking about our
appreciation for people who go to the
movies and those are you people so we
wanted to say thank you to the
moviegoers say thank you the movie goers
everybody surprised for you as well
I notice you don't have any snacks and
especially considering the smell in this
theater
[Applause]
now moving like a hot dog does anyone
want a hot dog alright let's fire do not
aim a hot dog
so go ahead fire that thing into the
carafe
[Applause]
captain coming to oh this is better than
Halloween this is a lot of fun
[Applause]
this guy what's your name come up here
for a second
Oh
are you doing the wrinkle at time so far
loving it have you found out of the
wrinkle is you
but have you ever have you ever done an
introduction on an award show before
hey guys Mike here is going to do an
introduction so Mike all you have to do
is just read that card alright here we
go Mike is going to introduce our next
presenters
hello billion people watching I'm Mike
young movies truly are magic one moment
you can be sitting in the theater
watching one then the next minute you're
on the Oscars introducing Tiffany Hudson
patches punished banished and Maya
Rudolph here
please welcome Tiffany Haddish and Maya
Rudolph oh you're
[Laughter]